hey what's up guys my name is Jonah and
welcome to episode 27 of network chat
programming so today we're going to talk
about if the client kind of disconnects
you're not cleanly if it's all dirty and
stuff in this kind of disconnection and
what happens is I don't know that the
user decides to force quit it or you
know terminate the process if you're on
Windows or if the computer just loses
power and crashes or the computer
crashes right or if or if the the client
loses a network connection for whatever
reason the server can no longer contact
the client okay so it needs to keep the
client out of there because the client
is no longer connected okay and we need
to handle that so what we'll have to do
is we've got this little thing here
called managing all right we've got this
manage clients method and what we're
going to do in there is well as you
probably gasps we're going to manage our
clients and the way that we're going to
do that is every so often we're going to
send a bit of a ping all right
so for each of these clients here right
for in I equals 0 is less than client
size I plus plus and by the way pro tip
you do not want to go ahead and make a
for each loop so if your clients I see
clients writing this will actually look
Trevor client client and you'll have C
as a as a thing and it should have been
serving clients for us but you don't
want it you don't want to do this oops
so a client you don't want to do this
because occasionally you can get issues
when you run into multiple threads and
you can have thread concurrency issues
so don't do it this way ok a followed
rather than for a for each loop do one
of these it'll be much much safer and
you'll get much less exceptions and
problems ok important ok anyway so what
we'll do is for each of these clients
will essentially send something to them
and then we'll kind of want to get a bit
of a response from them ok so I just
realized that instead of doing this way
we could just simply go ahead and go
send to all we'll send a message ok
and we'll start this with something
along the lines of I don't know I don't
want to start with C we'll start with I
I don't know why I would just start with
I and then we'll just send a message
kind of like server I don't know we
could say ping whatever so we'll send
that to each of the clients
let's terminate this looks like we're
still running the server
all right so while running we'll send
will send each of them one of these
things and then what we'll have to do is
we'll have to see what their response is
okay so how are we going to do that how
we're gonna see if the client has
responded on well what we're going to do
is we're going to actually make another
ArrayList here right we'll make a
private list of server clients oh no
actually no not a private list our
client's my bad
we'll make a private list private list
of strings and we'll call this client
response and we'll set it equal to a new
ArrayList of strings of course and what
we'll do here is basically we'll go back
here and we'll say if if we start so
we'll do another elsif in our process
here else if our string here starts with
an i then we know that oops
make sure you close that off as well and
get rid of this all right great syntax
is awesome now what we're going to do is
essentially what we'll say that as long
as the client is kind of I don't know as
long as the client as has kind of
replied to us right if it starts with an
eye that's kind of like a server kind of
checking reply thing we'll go ahead and
we'll add it of course into the client
response so client response don't add
and then of course we might go ahead and
just split it straightaway so string
which is string whoops dot split and the
rejects is that we'll use
aren't just / I / or / a / okay
and then we'll go one so in other words
because we expect to get the kind of
message we'll just make sure that if we
get a message such as we'll probably
send the ID so if we get a message such
as that
we'll just extract the important data
which is the middle out of it it'll just
probably tell you the integers but it
doesn't really matter
so um let's move this one inside of
course and we should be sweet
yep we asked for it okay right okay now
what we want to do is now that we've
kind of got the
arraylist and the reason we do this is
because we'll check them one at a time
kind of thing I'm a little rest in
between but what we'll do is we'll say
as we're managing this we'll say um that
essentially for each of the clients here
so foreign I equals 0 is less than all
of our clients I plus plus what we'll do
is we'll say that if I guess if the
client response dot contains let's see
so clients don't get I thought sorry
clients get I don't get ID right so in
other words if our client response does
not contain an ID with this stuff then
what we actually need to do is obviously
there's a problem ok because the client
hasn't replied to us yet so what we'll
do is we'll handle that now one thing we
have to do I just realize let's just
change this string into integer ok
that's probably going to make things a
bit easier now if we go down here
instead of adding us this fringle split
will also have to add an integer dot
parse int and then we'll just kind of
come in here and make sure that it's
been cost for an integer okay just like
that and then we'll just make it a bit
easier to competitor without having to
always do those kind of things so one
thing we need to check is because
remember in this was a while ago and I'm
sorry that I I'm on the getting to this
now but we have our server client yeah
and we've got this variable in a called
attempt and we created that when we
created this class but I didn't really
talk about all that so I covered her it
later and here we are that was some nice
foreshadowing for you guys some some
sick breaking bad style foreshadowing so
um in other words if we do if we're not
containing in right we also need to
check if our attempts archive gonna go
back kind of expired so if clients dot
in fact let's do this so client
sorry server client C equals clients
get I and then we'll just put a see here
if C dot attempt right it's greater than
or equal to let's just say our max
attempts and we'll make a quick filled
up here called private final int max
attempts and we'll set it equal to five
for now so in other words the the client
has five chances to respond until it's
basically disconnected so it's kind of
like a retrying connection kind of thing
so in other words if our attempt is
currently greater than max attempts then
we need to disconnect that client so
we'll go ahead and go disconnect c-dawg
get ID with the status of false so in
other words it was an unclean accent
however if if we haven't reached our
maximum attempts yet keep trying
so all we'll do is we'll go ahead and
set C dot attempt plus plus okay that's
it okay so this is what happens this
stuff here that we just read the the we
just wrote all this stuff happens only
if we couldn't find a client response
from the client from one of the clients
only if one of our clients didn't
respond to us so we asked them hey man
how's it going and he just sat there
like an idiot and didn't reply to us cuz
he's mean that's a bad thing that's why
we want to disconnect him okay
however if we did receive it as a
response then everything's great lies
right so what we want to do is we want
to remove that client response clearly
cuz we loose it because we're gonna send
these now well pretty pretty often
client response don't remove the idea of
the client now we can't simply go ahead
and say C get ID and the reason is
you'll notice that remove you can
actually if you just hover your mouse
here you'll see that it's actually using
the int index or a move okay so what is
doing is rather than removing this will
actually give us a size out of bounds
exception because what will happen is
we're trying to remove the ID but it's
thinking we're talking about the index
cuz they're both integers so what if we
go ahead and go new integer and then
enclose it in that you'll see that it
actually uses a different method to use
the object method which is the one with
the one we want okay so great we've
removed it now what we want to do
now what we want to do is obviously also
clear the number of attempts so cidade
attempt equals zero okay because maybe
it took a few times for it to work but
if it did work in the end we want to
clear those attempts otherwise if we're
stuck on four attempts and then it fails
for one other time gone the client's
disconnected we don't want to do that so
hopefully this will work okay so to test
this out it's gonna be a bit difficult
but that's alright to test this out what
we'll do is oh this is the other thing
we should mention this is this is gonna
use an awful lot of processing power
okay this is doing it as fast as it can
there's no need for it to be doing it as
fast as it can
the other thing you'll probably notice
is this attempt will happen really
quickly okay maybe the clients a bit
slow this will happen really quickly
it's probably this kind of decline in
about two seconds so what we want to do
is after we send we just want to wait
for a while okay and how do we do that
well we just sleep for a while okay so
we'll type in thread don't sleep
probably about around two seconds hmm
now let's write don't sleep happens to
be pretty inaccurate we don't care about
that in this case we're not using it for
any kind of timing we're using it to
kind of just slow down okay because we
don't need to be doing this all the time
so what this will do is it'll kind of
free up the system resources better to
do with this thread in particular this
managed thread we can also do you
probably wouldn't notice manage sleep
but normal other uses it like that you
can see that it's actually a static
method because thread does like what we
do kind of pick up on which thread it's
being executed in and thus it'll make
this specific manage thread sleep not so
won't make our listen thread sleeps
don't worry about that okay thread doll
sleep is awful for timing but it's great
for if you just want to take a break
okay and this will make this will make
the wild running loop run a lot slower
so probably run once every two seconds
or so and with a few nanoseconds geotag
but that will just make sure that we're
not running as fast as we possibly can
because it's useless to us we don't want
to be using their memory resources for
something that simple now let's save
this and start server main we'll also
start our login here sojourner
localhost 8 1 9 2 great and we'll go
ahead and hit login now if we were to go
up and you guys can't see this now but
I'm just going to the Apple menu and
force quit
if we're going to force quit or we could
do this inside clips as well but if we
go this is our comm dot the show notes
on the tarnish out dot login if we force
quit that and we force quit it then it's
gone and I think so is elf server did I
serve you as well there no I didn't hear
it is so oh here we go and then we get
client show no time down so you guys
didn't see that because it's switched
views unfortunately let me just see if I
can kind of organize that's a bit better
what we'll do here is go back to console
the so you can see the service still
running if we start the client out
flying up again and I'll keep the view
on the server I actually won't be able
to in a minute but local Jose I want
mine to login what I'll do is we've
logged in here what I'm gonna do is I
want to I'm gonna exit the server
let me just ignore this first time down
right I've just logged in again with an
identifier of five two seven seven what
I'm gonna do is I'm going to go back
here and I'm going to switch to the
client into something the client now and
close it and then switch back to the
server so what essentially I've just
demonstrated is what what will happen I
guess if we are if we don't send
anything so you can see it's time yo and
we're disconnecting so what will happen
but obviously we haven't made the client
reply yet okay so if I go ahead and I
start server main again because I'm not
running anything that was a very
important stretching but I'm sorry about
that but if I start up if I start this
up again go localhost I wanted to hit
login and I just wait here for like five
seconds on it'll be ten seconds actually
but let's just wait for a while okay you
can say that actually in debug every now
and then we're getting another ok and
there we go we timed out okay because it
sent its sent out its Santa's those five
kind of attempts but we never replied
and the reason we haven't replied yet we
are and if you've taught online a test
it won't return to us okay because the
server's just connected us now I'm the
reason it's disconnected us and we can't
send this anymore because we're
disconnected but the reason it
disconnection does is because it didn't
get those messages back and why didn't
get those messages back because we
haven't actually coded the client to do
that okay so over here in client window
where we have all of our courier
let me just make some more room here
real quick come on yeah yeah
in our let's say okay it's a message
starts with M go ahead and go else if
message starts with I okay / I / then
what happens is it's clearly a the
service tryna get into context would
look contact with us so in this case all
we'll do is we'll say let me just think
for a minute I guess we'll just say
something on the lines of well string
I'll string text will P and I along with
our ID so client ok ID along with an 8
at the end and we'll just simply go
ahead and send that text right I think
we called it text yeah we did and this
will be false so we don't want to print
it to the console or anything and that
should work okay and now the service
shouldn't time us out so if we go back
into here that's why we have those
attempts as well cuz occasionally our
network might drop out for like five
seconds and want five seconds there's a
lot for like 500 milliseconds and we
don't want to instantly disconnect the
client so we'll launch a um it will
launch a server main here launch that
beast go to login and launch that best
sure no localhost a one-line to login
see here we've logged in let's just wait
a while and if you come into here you
can see that I keep showing yeah you see
you see that kind of thread that just
points for a second that's I'll sending
the pain okay and you can see it's not
letting us out we're still here great
isn't it it is pretty sweet
so now if we go into the client into
login here and we terminated so we're
not ending and clearly we're terminating
it you can see here you can see the
server is still sending that it's not
getting a reply anymore so wait for like
three more times to and then last one
and then now
we get the client timed out okay so what
happens is the server's tried to send
five messages and it's gone none of
those back in a row so in other words
we've timed out and it's just connected
to us from the server and you can see
it's no longer sending that anymore so
that's how that works I hope that kind
of cleared it up for you guys that's how
we disconnect if it's not a if it's not
a clean disconnection okay if the if the
client permanently loses their internet
connectivity or for some reason there
can be two crashes we can disconnect
them as well okay that's pretty much it
guys
we are done okay in terms of actual I
guess some in terms of actual chat
application we're done this is the end
of network chat programming so if you
guys were looking for the kind of the
bare minimum without any kind of plugins
I guess I call them then you're done
this is now a fully functional chat
application okay now the next few
episodes I'm going to show you guys how
to do a few of the things that you
requested one of the pictures was
private messaging one other question was
to see clients how many clients are
online and stuff like that and to see
who's online okay that was a requested
feature and then there was another um
feature that I think well I'm probably
gonna that next episode I'll show you
guys how to actually use I guess give
commands to the server so if you're
running the server you can see who's
online how many clients are on and like
a command based interface and then will
implement a similar thing for um for for
the client-side GUI but um that's it
okay hope you guys enjoyed this episode
of network share programming great
series and then the next episodes are
pretty much just expanding on what we've
done but this is the entire framework
for network shadow application and then
soon we'll move on to doing this stuff
in game programming series for
multiplayer okay so essentially not
chatting of course well we might add
that but primarily of course being able
to play this is like an MMO essentially
but on our game programming series
anyway thanks a lot for watching guys
please hit the like button for what is
officially kind of unofficially I want
to say the last episode and network chat
programming and I'll see you guys in the
next episode net open up watch a
programming later guys
you